obviously we're a little bit of jitters
i was excited nervous to be out there
um
just wanted to not let my guys down i
thought our guys brought energy i
thought
we could have played better there was
some sloppiness that's kind of
reflective of where we are and probably
a lot of us at this stage uh first time
in the stadium
not really too concerned about the stats
you have credit where credit's due they
have a great defense especially
defensive front
and they made some plays and
we weren't able to win the game today
all right guys i appreciate you i was
talking with the team a little bit
afterwards make sure i checked on every
player so i'm sometimes slow out of the
locker room so i appreciate your
patience
[Music]
joe judge a little slow out of the gates
his first game as head coach the new
york football giants look got a tough
draw he doesn't make the schedule they
play the steelers once every four years
they got to play them last night yeah
start this season right with no fans
present so hey all things considered
i think it went better than it could
have for joe judge yes they lost 26 to
16. yes there was a late-game touchdown
that ultimately didn't make much of a
difference but either way either as to
the outcome of the game or as to the
outcome of any wagers placed on the game
but but still
they should have been blown off the
field i was stunned the line was only
six points for that game i think the
steelers a dramatically better team
and it could have been a much longer
night for the giants i thought they did
a good job of keeping the game
competitive for much of the first half
well yeah no question i mean you know
first off like what you said let's let's
be realistic about this did we really
think the giants were going to beat the
pittsburgh steelers the giants are in a
rebuild mode you know i mean and thanks
oh yeah joe judge he must have been like
oh great i get to play pittsburgh
opening week you know we have offensive
line issues i got a rookie left tackle i
got a second year quarterback i got a
brand new offensive coordinator and
defensive coordinator i mean it couldn't
get any harder and you're right the
steelers are in a different class as far
as just a put together football team
right now and the giants i thought hey i
knew you i know they lost 26 to 16 but i
kind of echo what you said i still think
it was a good look in which they played
and they were competitive in the
football game you know pittsburgh gives
them the early turnover kind of gets
them three points gets them confidence
daniel jones makes the big throw
and all of a sudden we're sitting there
in the third quarter right mike and i'm
going whoa it's 16 to 10 and daniel
jones is danny dimes right now and
they're driving down the field on the
steelers
and then the steelers make a typical
steelers defensive play knocked the ball
in the air and
the rest was history after that
pittsburgh took control of the football
game
yeah and it really did feel belated that
the pittsburgh steelers got to that
point but it felt all game long like it
was inevitable it was going to happen in
large part because one of the best
running backs in the nfl
had one of the worst nights any running
back in the nfl has had since the merger
saquon barkley becomes only the sixth
running back since the 1970 afl nfl
merger to have 15 or more carries and to
have 10 or fewer yards in the game you
almost have to try to have the ball 15
times and only gain six total yards but
that's what happens when number one your
offensive line isn't very good and
number two you're going against the
pittsburgh steelers i still submit that
barry sanders is the only guy under
circumstances like that that could still
find positive yardage well yeah you're
right and you know even him i saw him in
some days outmatched on the detroit
lions coming to giant stadium and
similar looks just like that where you
get the ball and the dam breaks you know
anybody watching that game last night
you can't sit here and realistically go
well saquon didn't do a good job i they
could have brought out the hulk and the
avengers all right i don't care who the
hell it was you weren't they weren't
going anywhere last night i mean every
time he got the ball he was swarmed and
that steeler defense
i mean mike i know we've talked about it
a lot this off season but man i mean
they just hit the ground running they
are so talented and dominant and unique
in how they call their defense and just
physical uh i
to me they were one of those teams that
looked like
it didn't matter we didn't have
preseason we've been hitting all along
in training camp we're ready to go let's
play some football it was it was a good
look for their defense to start
not a surprise either no because every
message we had gotten from mike tomlin
out camp has been one of unity no
players opted out no players tested
positive every player was wearing the
same name antoine rose jr on the back of
their helmet last night this is a team
that does everything as a team and
they've always been that way remember
the last cba 2011 one happened they all
voted against it as a team right mike
tomlin is able to pull all those
individuals together and get them all on
the same page and that that attitude
yeah that's interested itself last night
everyone was on the same page right
here's saquon barkley we mentioned
15 carries six yards saquon barkley
talking about his rough night in the
first game of his third nfl season
i got to be better am i gonna be better
for the team
got to find a way to get the run game
going um
uh
you know
that that's that's just how i truly
believe i gotta go back and watch film
um just to give you an honest answer um
you know i can't just talk off emotions
but uh one thing that just pops off in
my mind is final way to get the run game
going for this team i know that's going
to be a key part of our success and i
truly believe in and i still believe in
it and um you know just keep grinding at
it keep working at it and find a way
now look i mean not a whole lot of
teams got their running game going week
one and i i wonder if come monday night
some of the other teams should have
realized the running game may not be
there at this point maybe the offensive
line isn't ready to push the defensive
lineman around yeah that's right like
they normally do i mean i saw a lot of
derrick henry running outside we're
going to talk about that game later uh
now benny snow
who ended up carrying the load after
james connor exited with an ankle injury
benny snell showing he can get it done
19 carries 113 yards so the steelers
again
defying expectations because they are
the ultimate team and they did have that
statement in the running game that other
teams didn't uh and and you know it's
funny we went into week one with all the
indications james connor was going to be
the bell cow for the steelers
if you can't run if you can't play if
you can't suit up because of injury and
you're a running back next man up and
the next man up is going to get 113
yards on 19 carries you're the first man
down and this is now i think gonna be
benny snell's job especially if james
connor misses more than a game or two
with this ankle injury and i know it's
frustrating but when you're a running
back
you have to be able to play that's the
one thing that made emmitt smith the the
all-time leading rusher he wasn't the
fastest wasn't the most agile wasn't the
strongest wasn't the biggest wasn't you
know the best from a talent standpoint
but he was the most durable yeah so he
kept going and going and going and going
and that's the key and benny snell's
going to get the chance to do that but
saquon barkley is going to have to make
it happen and you know and again it's
one game that's right roll it up in a
ball and throw it in the trash can right
move on to the next game how teams react
to disappointing performances how
players react to disappointing
performances first one is going to be
the important factor going forward chris
well it is and you know to be realistic
about the situation too you know they
like you said like you said i believe
even monday morning just going yeah well
if this team had a different week one
opponent we might be looking at them
differently going into week two but they
got the short stick or the short straw
whatever the hell that is they got
pittsburgh who's angry and pissed off
and got more big bad dudes on their
football team than just about anybody in
football and the giants are still
finding their way saquon's a space
runner he had no space last night so
they're gonna have to continue to work
on that as the new york giants as far as
getting him the ball you see what he can
do when he gets the screen or something
out in the pass game how special he can
be when you just give him something but
he's not like derek henry who i know
we'll talk talk about in the in the
second segment where you can just go hey
there's nothing there just put your
shoulder down big boy and knock them all
down for three or four yards there's
nothing there that's not what saquon
barkley does that's not in his game it's
never been part of his game so they're
gonna have to work on that and then mike
the question you bring about
pittsburgh's running back i mean i don't
know you tell me let's have a combo
about it to me it's the the biggest
question about their team is that
position i mean it was very
underwhelming
looking overall production-wise i
thought until
okay now steelers got control of the
game they finally started to wear the
giants out the giants d was on the field
a little bit and like you said it
started to show the steelers were in a
little bit of a different class and yeah
they started to open up some big holes
but still a concern for me going forward
i i wasn't overly impressed with how all
the running backs looked there in
pittsburgh
yeah maybe they have to pass to set up
the run which is yeah they ultimately
had to do last night let me just take a
brief pause here because when you said
short stick and then said short straw
you meant to say short end of the stick
and that's not a sims isn't we're not
going to tell that thing for tomorrow
but i do need to tell you yes we now
have our loyal fans of this program
constantly on the lookout for sims-isms
in other shows
i got an email yesterday
from somebody who pointed out that
on judge judy's show your neighbor judge
judy by the way yeah a plaintiff said
the truth is in the pudding so
i like it it's what could have been
right a sims-ism uttered by a plaintiff
on judge judy so they are looking for
sims isms wherever they may find them uh
who knows there will be
a version of the dictionary where the
word simsism becomes a word instead of
one of the sims-isms themselves the
steelers have ben roethlisberger back it
was his first game in nearly a year 52
weeks since his elbow injury 21 for 32
229 passing yards three touchdowns zero
interceptions uh two sacks total for the
game one of the first half one in the
second half he looked at one point like
he was grabbing at his knee a little bit
we'll talk about that later here's
here is uh both ben rosenberger and juju
smith schuster talking about the return
of big bet
i feel great right now obviously
adrenaline is still probably pumping and
we won the game i'm going to be sore
tomorrow there's no doubt i've got some
bumps and bruises but
um
in terms of elbow and everything else i
feel i feel really good right now him
being out of it for one whole year and
coming back you know it kind of started
off slow on our offensive side but you
know once we picked it up and once man
forgot you know what he liked you know
we executed the face you know basic
simple plays went out there and dominate
and like i said you know ben's always
been ben and as you can see he did today
every time i see juju smith schuster i
think he's younger than my son oh and he
is younger than myself my son's 24 by
the way today it's my son's birthday i
tell him happy birthday he loves you he
likes you morning he likes me
man happy birthday alex what i mean way
to go you deserve a big happy birthday i
hope your rich father gets you an
awesome gift okay okay that's enough all
right that's enough awesome gift just
tell me what you want and i will batter
him and we'll get it done alex you the
man dude i mean you just seriously you
deserve i mean you was a father oh you
deserve to get him a really good gift
come on and i had a flashback to last
year i was interviewing juju's miss
schuster about this time in the season
yeah and he was doing a spot with tide
as his sponsor and at one point i said
to him juju you're younger than my son
you ain't washing your clothes and he
started laughing it's like yeah i stay
but he's 24 and uh well you know what
happens when he's home
who juju
yeah juju is real happy because all that
talk he's not a number one receiver he's
not a number one receiver well he had
two touchdowns last night doesn't matter
whether he's the number one receiver or
not if he scored touchdowns no exactly i
mean that that to me he just looked so
happy on the field yesterday in general
even after the game when big ben's being
interviewed he runs over that's my
quarterback because he's going damn it
feels good to be an offense again that a
quarterback can spread the ball around
the field and take advantage of what i'm
good at and big ben you know mike i
think you said it he started out getting
hit a little bit little rusty i think
more than anything he was just getting
used to the chaos around him and he's
trying to you know make sure he stays
out of harm harm's way to to a degree
like i remember he missed that first
third down out route right to the right
side i think he threw it a little high
he was protecting his legs you know he's
just getting used to the the mosh pit
once again which there is something to
that even for a guy in a legend like big
ben but you know overall
i thought really he settled in nicely
after that tj watt interception that
gave them the short field touchdown and
then when they got the two-minute drive
right before the half i went all right
big ben settled in here goes the
steelers offense let's see what they got
and we saw some young good-looking
receivers that could help them out this
year
yeah he made it clear leading up to week
one he was going to be more nervous than
anyone with that much time between games
all the focus all the effort all the
attention paid to getting that elbow
right and getting the rest of his body
where it needs to be and when that game
ended he had that he had that football
he was no one was getting that football
out he's taking that football home after
his first game back but you know chris
and with big ben you never quite know
when he's really injured that's part of
the legend that is ben roethlisberger
but at one point when he ran the ball he
scrambled away from pressure he kind of
reached down and grabbed his knee and i
was watching after that to see if there
was any type of limping any type of
anything and with ben you come to expect
limping even when there's no reason to
limp but he seems fine he seems healthy
it looks like he got through the game
unscathed now 15 more to go but so far
so good from a health standpoint for ben
roethlisberger yes but i i won't lie
there was a few times early on in the
game where i looked over at my wife and
i went
man
i don't know
florio might be right honey and she's
like what do you mean i i was like he's
been set he's been saying is this you
know is he just too beat up is he gonna
be okay i you know i was a little
worried about him really the way it
started yeah grabbed his knee early on
kept grabbing this and that yeah he's a
little bit like that i guess a showman
or a diva that way but
i'm just glad he made it through and i
just think we see
if he can stay healthy
they got a good o-line you see the
receivers to go along with juju smith
shuster james washington looks better
deontay johnson looks better we saw a
little flash from my man chase claypool
we saw eric ebron and you start to go
damn okay if they can protect that big
sucker down back there and he can be
somewhat consistent that defense is
super bowl caliber and uh they really
they could shock us all and be one be
that team in the super bowl for the afc
this year
and again you never know how good the
team is that beats you you never know
how bad the team is that you've beaten
it's entirely possible the steelers have
beaten a team that's going to be in
disarray all season long we just don't
know we won't know until we see more
games until we see good teams come
across good teams when they play the
ravens when they play teams that you
would look at and say yeah we know
already that's a good team but the
steelers we have every reason to believe
they are going to be a good team with
the giants we just don't know what
they're going to be glass half full they
did play well danny dimes played well
first half the 41-yard touchdown to
darius slayton i mean look uh they've
got something going on offensively with
jason garrett there we talked about that
in the off season the idea that jason
garrett despite any and all flaws as a
head coach is still a damn good
offensive coordinator he may be this
generation's norv turner where he's good
enough as an offensive coordinator to
keep getting coaching jobs he fails at
and at some point you just accept the
fact i'm going to be an offensive
coordinator and be the best offensive
coordinator i can possibly be and you
know it was working now as you said the
running game wasn't there but with the
passing game it definitely was there
yeah i mean it was there enough to keep
them competitive and again let's be
realistic about what we saw from daniel
jones we saw a lot of good we saw a guy
that was playing quarterback and was
severely outmatched as far as his
offense compared to the other defense
and you know when you talk about cameron
fleming at right tackle who's kind of a
career journeyman and then you got a
brand new rookie left tackle and andrew
thomas starting there out of georgia
man um hey they must have been like geez
we got to go with tj watt and bud dupree
and stefan tuitt and cameron hayward and
tyson olualu i mean
they got some beast up front so he was
under duress but once again i think
daniel jones showed he's capable of
making plays and kind of putting the
team on his back at moments i mean that
drive
that ended up with the interception on
the one yard line which ended up being
his worst play of the day because he
scrambles to the left the game 16 to 10
you're going whoa the giants score a
touchdown here and this game goes 17-16
we're gonna have a ball game it's going
to go down to the very end they've hung
they've hung around long enough to where
you're going to go okay here we go
and that was the worst play it was nice
not feeling where bud dupri was but i
know you and i were texting on that
drive be before that
i mean as that drive was going on and he
was on point whether it was scrambling
you know the fourth down conversion
backing up back leg saquon barkley high
level throws again i just think daniel
jones showed that he belongs in this
league and he's he has a chance to be a
special quarterback
one of the most important items on the
stat sheet the absence of fumbles for
daniel johnson that's right there were a
couple of occasions you saw him cover
that ball up he's aware he knows what
happened last year with 18 fumbles the
most by any player since 2002 dante
culpepper i believe we talked about that
in the off season
but you've got to have that clock in
your head you've got to get rid of the
football the interception in the first
half too it was just a very athletic
play by t.j great anticipation right uh
dropping dropping out of the pass rush
posture and jumping up and catching the
ball but that was a quick bang bang type
of a thing and you're right you know you
can't hold on to the ball for that long
against the steelers defense unless
somebody pops wide open
you're gonna eventually get yourself
into trouble against the steelers
defense if you have the ball that long
yeah that's right and i think you know
with the way you can look at it too a
lot of positives like we just mentioned
and the interceptions
i think are even
ones you can look at as a coaching staff
and go hey interceptions are never good
and we know that but these are two that
you'll be able to deal with if you're
coaching the quarterback or jason
garrett the first one yeah pittsburgh's
got million-dollar players over there
too i mean tj watts he's nfl defense mvp
candidate he's that type of player makes
a great play it's a slant route he reads
the three-step drop he jumps up he
intercepts the ball i mean that's
special the other one
again it's probably they're gonna the
coaching point will be daniel jones your
scramble to the left you gotta feel that
guy there just throw it away
live to play third down and let's see if
we can punch it in then but i think that
you know the point you brought up about
the fumbles and everything i i thought
there was a you know a consciousness
about that last night even a few times
where i felt like he went to the first
read went to the second read and was
like wait i could probably sit here and
get to the third read but things are
getting a little tight here let me get
out of dodge and those are things last
year i didn't see where i think he just
set would have sat in the pocket
continued to pat the ball and i think
you're already seeing a guy kind of
learning and progressing and getting
used to the nfl
how difficult is it to run to the left
when you're right-handed and for you it
would be run to the right right
left-handed well yeah run opposite your
throw while a guy is chasing you and
trying to throw the football accurately
and is there a point where you just say
screw it i'm not patrick mahomes i'm not
going to try to do this well there is
there's a point where you got to be
realized okay the guy that's chasing me
bug dupri is big and he's every bit as
fast or faster than me and especially
when you're running to your non-natural
side right so he's a righty running to
his left
you have to give yourself a little extra
time to get rid of the ball
in that scenario because to throw it
again because it's your unnatural side
there's going to be that little extra
i'm running the left but i got to kind
of gather my body and swing my shoulders
a little bit to get my body in the right
position to throw the football and
that's where
you know he misgauged or whatever you
want to say uh just didn't realize how
quickly duprey was getting getting on
top of him and again that's another
learning thing he's got to realize that
or just fall and throw the ball out of
bounds right he was he was out of the
pocket he didn't have to worry about
throwing it near a player or whatever it
is just make it look ugly and get it to
the line of scrimmage uh but that is
that's one that's going to keep him up a
few times this week
knowing the limits of your physical
abilities i think is critical for any
athlete no matter how accomplished they
are and the problem is you see guys with
unlimited physical ability and you think
you know what they can do it why not try
it myself but other than patrick mahomes
and and you know maybe tyler murray
maybe
yeah russell wilson could do that and
we'd be like we didn't even realize you
know exactly how homes does it and it's
and it's spectacular and we play it back
a thousand times but yeah that's a hard
thing to do it is running to your
opposite side with someone chasing you
and with my homes and you know it's just
it's it happens so fast you don't need
that extra time they don't have to
gather the body to make it yep exactly
yeah you're right though that's exactly
what they can just do it with their arm
where their body they can still run full
speed and their arm is so loose and
flexible and they can throw from so many
weird angles that they can just run and
they don't have to do that gather step
and turn the shoulders and do all that
quite the way you know most quarterbacks
have to do is what you're explaining
question
answer what is worse as a q well not yet
you don't know what the question is
question what's worse as a quarterback
having your teammates set you up first
in goal at the three and only getting
three points after they've put it on a
silver platter for you or
originating on your own a 19 play drive
and working 87 yards and ultimately
coming up with nothing oh well
they'll both piss you off when you come
away with you know three or nothing in
these two scenarios i think the more
heartbreaking one though is the 99-yard
drive you put in all that work you're
playing this great defense you're going
man we executed so many plays so well
other plays we didn't execute as well
but we found a way to get it done and
get first downs and keep mounting the
drive and keep it all going and then
when you get down there and you feel
like oh man we got this defense right
where we want them they're exhausted and
you let them off the hook there that
that's demoralizing because it really
like it's almost it's just a huge
momentum swing where you feel like you
got all the momentum and then just like
that
the defense that you thought you had on
the ropes and was tired and everything
like that now they feel energized and
it's like oh hey that didn't even happen
and you go back to the sideline going
damn you know what what do we got to do
here they put it in the end zone or make
this thing right uh so that's probably
worse even though that first one was bad
too
yeah i mean that's the thing not only
are you processing the disappointment of
not getting points you're dealing with
the frustration and the question of what
the hell are we going to do differently
the next time if that didn't work right
exactly right so you're sitting there
again one's going man can we just can we
punch it in can we go on a drive against
this defense with all the playmakers
they have and everything like that and
and of course pittsburgh they adjusted
too you know once they got beat deep by
darius slayton on that deep post route
and great throw by daniel jones
i i don't think there was too many
opportunities to put the ball up deep
the rest of the night i think pittsburgh
from that point on just said okay let's
see if this young offense can execute
and go on 10 and 12 play drives against
us and that was one of the few times
they did they put it together but it
just didn't end up the way they wanted
it to
where do you think the holes would be in
that defense based upon who they have
right now yeah uh the holes in that
defense the first thing that is there's
gonna be holes in the defense it's just
gonna be about can you protect long
enough
for your receivers to get to some of
those holes that's the big thing and i
still think pittsburgh
is not a great man-to-man defensive
coverage team but if you have just a
good idea of where blitzes are coming
and just not getting totally overrun
in the past game or in the in the with
the pass rush there's gonna be holes
because it's gonna be primarily zone
coverage that's why we saw brady and new
england carve them up for so many years
it's why you know i even think about
patrick mahomes against this defense and
i think that was his first game ever or
second game ever i believe out there in
pittsburgh same type of thing though
where if you got speed and you could
protect and you're you're in a good spot
to throw the ball there there's gonna be
moments where hey the guy's supposed to
go on a a 25-yard seam route but oh man
there's a avoided zone hit just throw a
rifle at him at 12 yards hey i'm
supposed to throw it at 25 but you know
the safety went deeper crossed the field
this linebacker dropped out this nickel
you know uh nickelback blitzed off the
edge and i got the ball and i just saw a
void so hey be ready to turn around you
got to kind of play a little street ball
against pittsburgh because it's not
going to be perfect you know your coach
can tell you all week like oh you know
when we run this play we want this
coverage and you get out there against
pittsburgh and you go hey coach i don't
know what the hell this coverage is
they're playing something over here and
something different over here and three
linemen dropped out so i don't know what
the hell that is you got to be able to
adjust on the fly that way and that's
where they kind of challenge you because
they'll challenge your rules and the way
you're coached and they kind of cause
chaos in the quarterback's brain
because nothing quite looks the way you
practiced or when even when you normally
play a game because they're a little
exotic that way
and just to illustrate how thin the line
is between victory and defeat even when
there's a 16 point deficit late in the
game the steelers are up six the giants
fail to capitalize on that long drive
right steelers drive down 62 yards in
nine plays for a field goal an important
three points to put it to nine not six
because six was the spread and they
missed two extra points already right
giants go three and out steelers get it
back and they suffocate them with the
drive that takes the clock from 12 23
down to 5 23 7 minutes off the clock
touchdown makes it 26-10 game over yeah
the giants get a touchdown late but it
didn't matter at that point made it
respectable it was a good it was a good
drive from the standpoint of how the
score is going to look in the newspaper
today to the extent that there are
already newspapers anymore i never know
but uh yeah 2616 looks better than 2610
but the reality is it was a hell of a
lot closer than that yeah it was you're
right i mean it was in it was in the
balance
we always felt pittsburgh was the better
team but
you know they were a little sloppy
and let the giants hang around and he
kept going man pittsburgh makes one
mistake here this is they're gonna they
could be in trouble
uh but you know luckily for them cam
hayward gets that interception and then
yeah finally pittsburgh put a drive
together got that field goal you said
and put put the giants in a tough spot
to where now you're going all right
giants you haven't been able to run the
ball and now you're down by nine and you
can't really waste time running the ball
at all now and that's not what you want
to be against pittsburgh and yeah
nonetheless cheap yards cheap touchdown
at the end of the game for the new york
giants they need the reps they need to
build on something offensively and
they'll take it they will that's at
least something positive and they put
enough good plays out on film to where
they'll grow as an offense from this
performance even though they lost
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports